Understanding South Africa's genocide case
against Israel, part one: some context.
On December 29th, 2023,
South Africa
filed an application to begin court
proceedings against Israel.
They argue that Israel is committing
genocide against the Palestinian
people in the Gaza Strip.
I'm going to go into detail
on this document in part three,
but these allegations
include killing Palestinians,
causing them harm
and trying to destroy the Palestinians
as a group.
South Africa submitted this
to the International Court of Justice,
which was set up in 1945
to settle disputes
between nations.
The final ruling will probably take years
to actually come out,
but the ICJ has come out and ruled
on a provisional measure,
ordering Israel to
“take all measures within its power
to prevent...genocide”
and crucially,
to “ensure the preservation of evidence”
so they can properly investigate this.
But they did not order Israel
to stop military operations
as South Africa had requested.
In part two,
I will explain what genocide actually
is per international legal definitions
so we can learn what that definition
teaches us about this case.